hi I'm Nick gaspie and editor at large
at reason your Source since 1968 for
everything related to free minds and
free markets we're in the middle of
reason's annual webathon the one time
each year we ask our online readers
viewers and listeners to support our
principled libertarian journalism we're
trying to pull in
$400,000 in new donations your gifts are
tax deductible and go directly to
funding our print journalism our video
Cs and our podcasts what's more they're
being matched so every dollar you give
goes twice as far if you like what we've
been doing and what we're going to keep
doing please give now go to reason.com
donate for giving levels and Associated
swag some of it's pretty great and from
all of my colleagues
[Music]
thanks